je suis complètement en train de la
futaie dans deux mois on m'appelle le
monstre pas
non mais qui alors je pense que c'est
non à biomasse trio alors elle est
encore vous affûté en fait ça fait des
mois que j'ai c'est de perdre du poids
son succès qui s'est passé un truc à la
rentrée je me suis fait escroquer par
matthieu delormeau qui m'a promis des
séances de sport contre une grosse somme
d'argent ah oui séance de sport auquel
il n'est jamais venu ah d'accord voilà
premier ça mais là si si si si ce n'est
la mort ni somme mirobolante qu'elle
battait après qui dit site a lâché là
bas je veux dire les vérités je lui
avais promis facturation bien fait je
lui ai promis de lui faire un programme
que je lui facture oui n'diaye ce que tu
peux venir j'ai si je viens c'est normal
c'est le facture de triple du jeu vient
sommes à cinq chiffres jusqu'où lire les
chiffres révisés alors g pour lino g
pour lui 5000 euros il y avait un
programme citoyen ou trois mois
mais vous êtes qu'il livre à mes secrets
beauté 1 quels secrets beauté
il me dit viens avec moi tous les jours
je suis je bien avec toi tous les jours
et je t'aide à te nourrir là
effectivement sur mon programme c'est
quinze mille
mais c'est du comment ça s'était
commence à nous ça il voulait me
facturer non manufacturés des vidéos
d'encouragement 250 euros la vidéo des
petits encouragements c'est vrai vous
pas que des gens qui s'est tu peux pas
aller le gras sur pc et non les biens
noblesse m'a fait changer mon jouet un
festin millimages ibra ne lâche pas
lâche patrice et ça c'est aussi ça
compte pas de 50
places et 500 euros de l'heure alors
voilà l'info car oui mais l'avocat cadet
d'argent il veut être bon ou pas qui lui
les résultats inédits non wagner stabilo
aujourd'hui j'ai remonté la pente j'ai
trouvé un coach honnête qui même pour
qui je suis voici rexie ses frais de mon
pauvre il s'appellera oui j'adore oui
oui c'est une belle personne
et 15000 euros par an
voilà très cher à coacher votre
avertisseur allez merci bâton agente on
m'a longtemps fait des avances il était
prêt à tout pour réussir faut croire qu
avec cyril ça a marché on a entendu on
l'homme
à dieu c'est mathieu ça fait plus j'ai
appris que cette hausse aux
jeux vous écrire mathieu
séguin alors
cette histoire c'est possible j'ai mis
la carte en expliquer lui-même non mais
moi j'ai un doute alors dites moi non
mais c'est sympa non en fait quand j'ai
commencé la télé j'avais 19 20 ans ouais
attention et c'est tout c'est ignoble
rade mathieu même ajouté sur facebook
le deuxième
volet 17 dirait qu'on se parle sur skype
donc on s'est parlé sur skype et pendant
une demi heure il a déblatéré n'importe
quoi et tu sais si tu veux réussir comme
moi animé tellement vrai faux travaillé
pendant dix ans vrai ou faux immo non
c'est vrai le début était vrai il nous
disons de télé pendant une demi heure
voilà mais c'est faux sur ces faux sur
skype et m'a dit voilà j'aimerais faire
de la télé comment faire je faisais kent
il en veut le moment ce cas mais comment
faire nana j'ai vu qu'ils poussaient un
peu j'ai dit non non non non tu pousses
et je me rends compte qu'en réalité
c'est dans un jacuzzi
le seul qui poussent en ce moment c'est
bien
[Rires]
parce qu'à l'époque il y était c'est à
dire sur secret story qui m'avait
expliqué qu'il ait fait connaissance
d'un certain mathieu melhem extrêmement
assistant extrêmement lourde opposition
c'est extrêmement prétentieux qui avait
expliqué tout le métier j'ai dit que
pour y arriver il fallait passer par son
bureau
vous connaissez forcément
n'ai pas d'argent mais parce qu'on
pouvait pas lui parler
le pape a qualifié ces craintes sur l on
pouvait pas y avait un garde du corps
tout le temps non mais il était très
sympa il était hyper sympa non mais en
vrai hyper serré mais c'était une énorme
star on pouvait pas l'approcher mais ce
qui est normal je veux enlever le passé
c'était ça me fait chier mais non mais
c'est une énorme star maintenant on peut
un peu la foule
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qui m'a vous achèterez c'est
ça sauf que comme il a un problème avec
les distancer au clair le
tiens en parlant de benjamin castaldi à
merde j'ai terriblement envie de me
refaire le sexe c'est pas dit c'est vous
qui avez dit ça c'est beau
jour nous avons reçu donc une
chirurgienne esthétique absolument
charmant oui regardez attentivement le
visage de de benjamin ses lèvres ses
paupières et tout ça et après l'émission
habitude de benjamin vous savez il part
très très vite et là pas du tout il
n'est pas du tout partie il est allé
dans les loges il était très agité très
fébrile il s'est approché de moi et
biome d'ailleurs on peut en témoigner il
a dit oh là là a vraiment donné envie de
me refaire le thème le sexe parce qu
elle était spécialisée parties intimes
est aussi bien un sexe de femme que les
sexes odom et donc ils étaient formels
il a dit qu'il avait très envie de faire
ça que j'aimerais refaire le sexe alors
qu'au départ d un devis c'est alors je
vais vous dire je me suis dit vous voyez
votre sexe police à cause de votre
non mais c'est vrai tu sers à rien alors
je me suis renseigné en fait l'opération
qui consisterait à
un agrandissement du pénis envahi le
problème c'est que sense à d'efficaces
corpo quant à ses propos a bien sûr
c'est que vous reposer jamais
en fait si on veut s'en fait l'opération
ça ne modifie pas l'érection nous
intéresse pas d'attenté téléphoner
enseigner excellence et des pâtissiers
3000 euros et en plus il vous faut de la
mine on vous foutent de la grèce dans le
mode de petites et les vieux
toujours largement dit moi je savais pas
toujours si oui
c'est sympa les gens là
[Rires]
j'ai un copain qui l'a fait selon lui
d'abord merci c'est un échec cuisant
c'est pas vrai c'est avec ces matches je
demande
c'est que benoît dubois benoît dubois le
sahara qui l'a fait oui et madre était
vraiment les détails ses cadres où il
était avec l'unique champs elysées au
qui m'ont dit ils prennent de la grèce
dans la fesse ils l'ont injectée dans le
nid et après nice est horrible médecins
avec des gants c'est comme ça
t elle exactement c'est comme les
boulettes ou quoi est parti pour que la
grèce ait fait ça l'arep ça il y avait
une petite forme il attend toi tu es là
tu es ridicule c'est comme ça il fait ça
jusqu'à une prévenance pareil et il m'a
dit que franchement ça a duré sept mois
mais patrick gras comme ça mais son nom
effectuera six mois à peu près à lui la
paix six mois sans rigoler franchement
je préfère être comme castaldi 1
alors oui j'ai pas vu celle de 14 ans il
peut le faire si tu l'as vu toi même six
mois à mai suivant gazette
[Applaudissements]
des dires il a été qu'est ce que tu as
vu je dis la vérité tu as vu jeu pardon
mais dit les vérités voire des sexes et
c'est ça qu'il avait plus de talent que
de musée
non mais
les yeux permet donc
c'est parce que tu as mieux voilà c'est
tout c'est parce que des mesures
allaient qu'auraient certains fans sur
epic ouattara auquel occasionner de dieu
mais il a vu une photo non ogm a vu que
jack était un poil tout le temps normal
moyenne facture je voyais ça beaucoup
plus petit non non a demandé à valérie
pascale avis aussi brillamment du coup
elle peut faire cette rue
cela dit nous complexer pas les gens ce
n'est pas grave du tout d'avoir un micro
non ce n'est pas une maladie
maladie
on fait tout saisir
non
[Applaudissements]
complique je suis pas les rôtis la
raison battu en année
pleine chez eux qui doit paraître sinon
me soulage josiane
secretstory la micro pénis
jamais c'est bien pire départ
on allègera les lilas petit zizi
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'a vu de dos ça pendait
[Applaudissements]
c'était une trouille
de ma miss était rien
c'était le rôle
de la robine et c'était la douche voilà
allez allez suivre les
derniers bons ce soir on va passer à ce
qu'il fallait pas louper c'est bien si
série de meutres est encore une fois de
[ __ ] je peux vous garantir que ça va
partir en sucette
mon pied j'ai entendu ça tombe bien on
me l'a dit même sur anr un peu agressif
au genre j'ai presque envie qu'ils me le
retraite de frayeur pour du monde
vraiment comment ça va se passer mais ça
va se passer comment en suisse est
alors nommé il m'a dit que c'est tous
les vrais kamke côté des perdants loges
si si alors
je lui péter la gueule josé bien trois
ministres hier c'était il ya trois
ministres qui m'ont appelé ils ont
peuvent plus je ne veux plus très têtu
soeurs ici il y va un peu mais il n'est
pas très courageux montiel 500 m berne a
quand même bien à monter c'est vrai que
je les dis ouais je déteste la vulgarité
si vous voulez alors
c'est pas vulgaire 1,6 mais pas du tout
ça ne sera pas du tout genre n'étant pas
du tout c'est une expression très
mignonne bien sûr à temps si tu t'y mets
tout à fait amicale
pas préféré nicheurs c'est pas vrai
j'aime bien très bien alors vous serez
à bouffer le cul sans fin ça m'excite
noyer
attends on peut pas tous vous fait le
cul de serre il ya un moment
[Applaudissements]
pour y aura plus rien à bouffer
cnc leyen sur la bête
mamie il aime vous faites la cuire
vous devriez m'accepter savent où
reposeraient
ça ne prend rien de ce qu'il dit c'était
quoi la van
wyk a compris laisse tomber laisse
tomber sa maman delphine vous et ça va
bien j'ai regardé la pauvreté
franchement voyez pas parce que l ai
oublié de subir ça je suis désolé
je peux vous dire qu'à 56 ans mon mec
est mieux gaulle et que toute la table
réunit
alors la raison voilà alors delphine
bravo puisque j'aime bien elle défend mm
et en plus il est bien gaulée
effectivement
moi mais ça se voit après un jour de
noël à dire un truc
à voter oui c'était pour c'était pour
clore voilà la dernière fois
effectivement d'un cas stadiers très
malin
c'est mon petit zizi semaine
aux yeux sont plus grand c'est que ça va